the Starks of Winterfell Trace their
descent to the first men in the age of
Heroes
the family's founder was Brandon the
Builder Who and the aftermath of the
long night helped establish the Night's
Watch
Legend has it he Enlisted the aid of
Giants and the powerful magic of the
children of the forest to raise the
mighty War
protected the realm for Generations
he went on to build the ancestral seat
of Winterfell and reign as the first
king in the North
the Starks take great pride in their
history and traditions
is one of the few Noble houses that
still keeps the old gods
sacred weirwood tree limbs large in
winterfell's godswood
its ancestral sword ice which was forged
in ancient Valeria and has been passed
down through the generations
house Stark remained steadfast in its
support of the Night's Watch even as the
once illustrious order has formed on
Hard Times
much like their sigil the gray direwolf
how Stark is the stuff of legend in the
north and throughout the Seven Kingdoms
and their family words winter is coming
serve as a reminder of their Beginnings
in the wake of the long night and a
grimportance of things to come you have
to wait two years until the next episode
of House of the Dragon so now is the
perfect time for you to listen to the
audiobook on which house of the Dragon
is based and you can listen to it now
for free that's right you can listen to
Fire and Blood audiobook for free it's a
Targaryen history book on which house of
the Dragon is based written by George R
Martin it goes from aegon's Conquest
until the end of the dance of the
Dragons which will also be the end of
House of the Dragon you can now listen
to it for free with horrible trial using
our link which you can find in the
description of this video all you have
to do is go to the description click the
link sign up for free audible trial and
choose Fire and Blood audiobook go and
listen to a long and Rich Targaryen
history including the current and future
events of House of the Dragon for free
like the Starks the blood of House
Bolton runs back to the first man
singers call those times the age of
Heroes
a mask for a Savage world that Breds
Savage men
the Lannisters swindled their enemies
the storm Kings hammered them and the
Starks cut off their heads
in such company as this
were the boltons really so indelicate
unlike some other houses my ancestors
owned the Bolton words our blades are
Sharp
they passed down not a Valerian great
sword but a knife honed and thin enough
to fit between the topmost layer of skin
and the tissue below
and peel
for as we all learned as children a
naked man has few Secrets a flayed man
none
in those dark days they say that some of
my more willful forbearers would even
wear their enemies skins as cloaks but
no such tokens remain if they ever
existed
certainly not hanging in some secret
room in the Dreadfort as old wives and
fools insist
I suspect my house itself was
responsible for spreading such Rumors in
the first place
few weapons are as effective as Terror
and this was an age of War
house against house brother against
brother
the Iron Man were on the rise and never
far from our Shores
we must have seemed ripe for the taking
too busy fighting each other to deal
with the Raiders as they deserved
thus the Starks took it upon themselves
to unify the north under them
they drove the Pirates out of white
knife and claimed the eastern coast and
married the marsh King's Daughter for
the neck a stark wrestled for Bear
Island and won
or so they say
silly stories Blood and Steel on the
North and the Starks had the most of
both
with most of the south in aegon's hands
the best chance to throw back the
Conqueror now lay with the north if we
cared enough to try unlike our Southern
Rivals the Stark Kings of winter didn't
Forge the north into one Kingdom for
Glory or gold there is little of either
here but to survive alone in Westeros
the north remembered when worse than
dragons lay waste to armies
thousands of years ago the sun set on
the Realms of men and the long night
began
a new race emerged from the ice and snow
the white walkers they demanded no Crown
offered no terms spared no life and the
dead marched with them with Humanity
facing extinction as Stark sought out
the children of the forest the most
ancient beings and Westeros and convince
them to Ally with the men they'd once
fought together the two races pushed the
Walkers back into the land of always
winter and sealed it off from the Seven
Kingdoms with the wall
300 miles of ice stone and Earth rising
nearly 700 feet tall
to guard it they established the Night's
Watch a Brotherhood sworn to defend the
living from the dead whose vows are
raised both titles and crimes
after the long night the north tried to
forget it belonged to a continent
perhaps who Pride perhaps through sheer
ignorance he never can tell with the
North
but as news of aegon's dragons spread
toronstar the king of winter knew he
couldn't forget Westeros any longer and
summoned his Lords to Winterfell
many fools Shrugged off the threat while
the rest placed wages on how long the
South would take to burn
torrent silenced them with a command to
assemble their armies and descend from
the North in force as the kings of The
Rock and the reach burned on the field
of fire the greatest Northern Force
since the long night crossed the neck
into the riverlands
but when King tauren arrived at the
Trident he saw on the opposing Riverbank
the combined strength of all aegon's
conquered kingdoms
Force larger than tauren's own by half
and with three dragons
that night King tauren called the
conference of all his Lords and advisers
some wanted to fight and Trust Northern
Valor to carry the day
burn on the Triton
the wisest of them wanted to withdraw to
mount kegelin The Fortress which had
thrown back every Southern invasion
and burn there one suicidal Lord even
wanted to Ambush aegon's camp in the
dark and kill the dragons as they slept
or at the very least their Riders it's
hard to tell what would have been his
fate burning
heading dismemberment
perhaps all three
my ancestor listened to their counsel
and in the morning cross the Trident
under a flag of parlay then King tauren
of house Stark laid his ancient Crown at
aegon's feet and was named Lord of
Winterfell and Warden of the North
and the king who knelt
he had no choice and thanks to him our
soldiers returned to their homes whole
and unharmed
swords that aegon took from them were
not Twisted burnt or mangled
[Music]
then came Lord Wentz tourney at
harrenhoe the largest ever in Westeros
ion horse every man against me until
only Prince rhaegar remained we each set
our feet in our Saddles and lowered our
lancers and charged
I fell
muddy and bruised are then watched
rhaegar presently Anna Stark with the
Victor's Crown of roses though she was
betrothed to Robert Baratheon a rhaegar
himself was married to Elia Martel we
all know what happened after if I'd been
a bit quicker with my Lance if I'd
chosen a faster horse perhaps I could
have spared the Kingdom from the
destruction that came after
or if I thought to warn Brandon Stark
against his rashness he came to King's
Landing himself demanding rhaegar return
his sister
if he'd only known the depth of Aries
madness he wouldn't have dared provoke
him Aries ordered Brandon imprisoned and
I could do nothing but obey
when Brandon's father Lord Richard Stark
came to King's Landing to beg for his
son Ares burned him alive
and I could do nothing but watch I had
sworn a vow to a Mad King and was honor
bound to obey him
even at the cost of my soul
we urged heiress to Pardon Brandon Stark
the boy had threatened Prince rhaegar
but rhaegar had stolen the boy's sister
and the boy was the eldest son of our
Warden of the North
who's the greater fool a mad king or the
man who reasons with him Aries saw
knives in every shadow when you told him
to treat the stalks with caution you
made him afraid and what he feared he
killed I wouldn't have thought you of
all people would bother with
recriminations for Brandon's death Lord
Baelish not after your shall we call it
duel with him Brandon was as arrogant as
he was stupid like his father Lord Stark
who answered Aries summon to the capital
they earned their Fates
but the younger son Ned what was his
crime that Ares ordered his death as
well
unlike men families don't die when you
Lop off their head
when did you know you'd lost Lord Varys
when Robert Baratheon killed Prince
rhaegar on the trident
wrong
you lost the war when you let Ned Stark
slip back into the North
neither the bloody gate of the veil or
more Kalin in the north have ever fallen
they could have held that for years even
if you'd killed Robert
would you let him slip through your
fingers as well
I told the court that Robert was hiding
in the Stony sept but the hand of the
king wasted too much time searching the
city something about the glory of single
combat
then Ned Stark's Army arrived to save
the day
Robert one and my husband Avenged his
brother and my love
but when he came home to me
could not meet my eyes
I saw the reason
by his side
many men have bastards I know
and under the strain of War any man no
matter how honorable May forsake his
vows for a night of warmth that he may
never know again
but Ned Stark was not built like other
men
his Northern honor would not let him
sequester his shame in some distant hold
fast
he brought this boy this Jon Snow home
to raise with his trueborn children
my children
stocks are of the north and like the
Snows of winter when they come South
they Melt Away
two years until season two is a long
period but you can still stay in the
house of the Dragon World by listening
to Fire and Blood audiobook for free
house of the Dragon is based on Fire and
Blood book and covers the entire
Targaryen history starting from aegon
the Conqueror and his Conquest as well
as maegor the cruel and other legendary
targaryens including the current and
future events of House of the Dragon go
and listen to it for free with horrible
trial using our Link in the description
foreign